[Música]
ah
para ti que es el comercio electrónico
comercio electrónico se podría definir
como la producción distribución mercadeo
venta y entrega de bienes y servicios
por cualquier medio electrónico es decir
puedes vender a través de un marketplace
puedes vender con tu propia tienda
virtual puedes vender por las redes
sociales o incluso por tu whatsapp de
hecho en esta crisis sanitaria en donde
los gobiernos del mundo necesitan
impulsar la reactivación económica y
reducir la propagación del contagio kobe
19 al mismo tiempo el comercio
electrónico es el mejor aliado para
hacerlo
en mi país por ejemplo y tu traje se
pensaba que iba a entrar al mundo de la
digitalización en este mundo del
comercio electrónico por lo menos en
cinco años han entrado en los últimos 90
días es increíble como por ejemplo
bodegas han aumentado su consumo online
en más de 70% panaderías más de 2.000 %
supermercados 205 por ciento educación
las personas ahora están invirtiendo en
capacitarse para sobrellevar la pandemia
ha aumentado en casi 200 56%
electrodomésticos tele trabajos de la
educación como para computadoras
refrigerador televisión ha aumentado
casi 900 70% consumo de moda 4.400 por
ciento restaurantes tradicionales no
fast food diez mil ciento noventa por
ciento
de hecho esto ha sido casi un pick band
digital el comité ha superado incluso
los mayores picos sauber que se dan en
el black friday noviembre incluso en
navidad el hobbit ha superado totalmente
cualquier expectativa y nadie estaba
preparado para ello algo interesante
resaltar si hablamos de volumen de
transacciones sin embargo es que todo
este volumen de transacciones el 97% ha
estado concentrado en la capital de mi
país lima solamente el 3% correspondía
al resto del país realmente hay mucho
por hacer por eso hoy quiero hablarles
de la otra cara del comercio electrónico
para mí hablar de comercio electrónico
es hablar de confianza aunque cueste
mucho entender lo que es la confianza
online
se podría decir que es un hipótesis
sobre la conducta futura del otro un
acto de fe en una persona o en una
entidad
quizás una apuesta a futuro esperando
que ésta sea capaz de actuar de manera
correcta
porque nos cuesta tanto ganaron la
confianza un consumidor
me gustaría contárselo y explicarles a
través de una historia real nací en mi
país en la sierra a más de 3.800 metros
sobre el nivel del mar una ciudad
llamada fuerabamba en el departamento
apurímac una historia de la vida real
qué puede hacer una analogía entre lo
que pasa en el mundo online y el mundo
offline veamos este en su pueblo que
está
sobre una mina muy rica en plata en oro
en cobre los mineros no sabían cómo
hacer para decirle al pueblo que se muy
de otro lado después de muchas
negociaciones con los líderes de la
comunidad
finalmente los convencieron diciéndoles
que les iban a construir un pueblo
entero a todo lujo lejos pues de esta
mina para poder explotar la
tranquilamente a lo que el pueblo
accedió bajo ciertas condiciones
uno de ellos fue
y tener casas en las cuales obviamente
vivan de manera cómoda pero los mineros
pues hicieron un esquema de vivienda muy
al estilo americano dos pisos
habitaciones a todo lujo totalmente
amueblado ya quisiera yo vivir en una
casa de esas sin embargo no era lo que
necesitaban los los amigos que vivían en
esta comunidad no ya que ellos por
ejemplo por el frío es una costumbre
dormir todos en una sola habitación para
luchar contra el frío o quizás también
defenderse de algún tipo de pillaje
a pesar de que habían contra
habitaciones sólo utilizaban una los
jardines que eran muy lindos los
utilizaban para hacer festividades en
fin ya veces uno se puede pensar cuando
hacemos ya en el mundo online este tipo
de supertiendas o super apps realmente
es lo que necesitan los usuarios a veces
quizás lo único que necesitan es una
experiencia simple rápida y directa algo
que realmente responda a sus necesidades
en el caso de nuestros amigos no eran lo
que necesitaban pero qué más da ahí
estaban y yo creo que si llevamos esta
experiencia al mundo online creo que nos
encontramos con un primer gran desafío
no solamente el comercio electrónico
sino también de la transformación
digital que es empatiza con las personas
lo que te importa a ti quizás nos les
importan los usuarios
otro tema interesante que a mí me parece
muy gracioso es cuando dentro de toda
esta mudanza que estaban haciendo todo
muy perfecto todo muy coordinado se
cumplieron todos los checklist en lista
y excepto que se perdió una gallina
señor ingeniero no encontramos la
gallina de la familia del bloque tal
pero pues no importa qué lío toma 20
dólares y cómprate otra gallina en
cualquier lado y cuando le llevan esta
gallina a la señora a la dueña la casa
inmediatamente reconoció que no era su
gallina lo siento señor ingeniero pero
esta enemiga llena pero como no lo va
hacer aquí está la gallina es de color
blanco o sea tiene que estar que de otra
forma puede ser su gallina no señor mi
gallina no responde a mi llamado se
llamaba juana tenía un ponchito cuando
la dejé en fin
esta experiencia graciosa y dicho sea de
paso la señora no aceptó su dañina pero
bueno se le compensó de otra manera si
esta experiencia la llevamos al mundo
online nos encontramos con una segunda
regla de oro del comercio electrónico
que es logística segura simple
compromiso entrega tiempo entrega lo que
prometiste llevar muy simple como eso y
al mismo tiempo muy complejo
otra cosa bastante interesante es cuando
les enseñan las fotos de cómo iban a ser
sus en sus casas a lo que a lo cual los
las personas que vivían en este pueblo
accedieron pero cuando finalmente llegan
a sus casas se dieron con la sorpresa
que no era igual a la foto que ellos
habían visto y habían aceptado y dieron
reunión con los ingenios y le dijeron
señores discúlpenme pero miren esta foto
es totalmente diferente a lo que yo
estaba esperando encontrar aquí pero
como que diferente si es la misma casa
el mismo color no no no señor mire bien
la foto hay unas camionetas en cada
puerta no señor disculpe está sola la
camioneta de los ingenieros lo siento
usted me enseñó esta foto y yo quiero mi
camioneta térmicas y como se podrán
imaginar le tuvieron que comprar una
camioneta nueva a cada una de las
familias de este pueblo y esto nos lleva
a si lo llevamos al mundo online ahora
la tercera regla de oro el comercio
electrónico transparencia la información
lo que ves en la foto es lo que vas a
recibir punto muchas veces en el mundo
online tenemos
por decorar mucho la página le metemos
mucho photoshop a las fotos y finalmente
esto lo único que logra es decepción en
las personas al recibir algo que es
diferente a lo que vio en la página webs
por favor ténganlo en cuenta
tratando de buscar otros medios como
empatizar como hacerse amigo de esta
comunidad y vivir realmente de forma
colaborativa en la sierra nuestro país
son una de las actividades que más prima
la agricultura es producción más que
nada de papas
nosotros somos un país productor de
papas de hecho tenemos más de 4.600
tipos de papas
pero lo malo es el precio que se le paga
este agricultor por su killer papa no
normalmente se cobra entre 20 centavos
30 centavos cuando estos ingenieros
fueron al pueblo le dijeron lo que el
señor nos gustaría comprarle
semanalmente su producción de papas
perfecto pero ahí la tiene agarre su
bolsa llévese las papas que quiera no no
no señor tranquilos cuando esté bien te
sugiere papá 20 centavos perfecto ayer
hoy le voy a pagar 5 soles 5 soles no le
puedo creer si 5 soles pero me la pela
me las lavas me las en bolsa y me las
deja todos los miércoles en la puerta la
mina
esto definitivamente cambió la vida las
personas empezaron pues a recibir un
ingreso del cual ellos no lo hubieran
hecho jamás
se sembró el bichito del emprendimiento
de las familias de este pueblo de hecho
no solamente se vendió papas luego esto
dio lugar a otros servicios y bueno esto
finalmente si lo llevamos al mundo
online no se encontraba bajo una cuarta
regla de oro el comercio electrónico 90
productos vende experiencias destaca por
el servicio si el mercado no percibe
diferencia va a seguir propensión al
final o eres diferente o eres barato
como hemos visto la confianza 300
cualquier cultura no se trata de
evangelizar una palabra que a mí
particularmente no me gusta porque suena
como que imponerlo
se trata de empatizar con los demás
seres humanos entender sus culturas sus
temores creo que sólo hay es con el
mundo online y el mundo offline
finalmente van a poder asumir así como
la señora en historia recordaba cada
detalle su gallina los consumidores
online contestan haciendo sus compras en
una tienda virtual cualquiera recuerdan
cada detalle de los productos que han
visto en línea se pasan minutos valioso
de su tiempo comparando tiendas y
decidiendo finalmente eligiendo y
confiando en alguien para que finalmente
le puedan entregar otra cosa por favor
no insultemos inteligencia empatizamos
cumplamos lo que prometemos es tan
simple como eso si vas a vender online
vende experiencias no compitas por
ofertas eres mucho más que eso se
transparente con tus procesos cumplen
los tiempos de entrega
creo que es importante construir una
reputación y todo esto se da
cumpliendo todo estos procesos que
estamos conversando si vas a emprender
en internet emprende con propósito sea
un héroe cambia el mundo pero empieza
por tu país y por favor nunca olvidemos
la confianza en los consumidores será la
moneda de pago en tiempo de pospandemia
gracias
[Música]